Solo: A Star Wars Story flew a little low
at the weekend box office, bringing in just
$103 million over the four-day Memorial Day
weekend: a huge drop from early tracking,
which predicted the movie bringing in $170
million or more.
It also marks the lowest opening for any one
of Disney's Star Wars films, below even Rogue
One, the franchise's first standalone film.
Telling the origin story of the title smuggler,
Solo should have been able to capitalize on
the legacy of its hero to become a huge box
office draw.
But there are a lot of factors that contributed
to Solo's disappointing box office performance,
so let's take a look at the real reasons the
film didn't perform as well as expected.
Star Wars fatigue
Solo is the fourth film to come out of the
new phase of the Star Wars franchise, and
the first not to hit theaters over the December
holidays.
While this may have led to a diminished opening
weekend, it also meant that the movie hit
theaters just five months after the release
of The Last Jedi, marking the shortest window
between the release of two Star Wars films
to date.
This may have contributed to some franchise
fatigue.
While the trilogy films have build-up to bring
fans in no matter when they come out, the
standalone films have to find a way to make
themselves seem like must-see entertainment.
Rogue One came out a full year after the last
Star Wars film, but for Solo, it may have
been hard to drum up interest so close to
the prior film's release.
A new take
Alden Ehrenreich landed the difficult task
of trying to live up to Harrison Ford's iconic
portrayal of Han Solo, and although some people
have praised his performance, others don't
think he quite lives up to his predecessor.
Part of the problem could be the script, which
shows off a much more optimistic version of
Han than the one audiences came to know and
love in the original trilogy.
In the role, Ehrenreich came across as charming
and fun, but also different from Ford's version
of the character.
While it was probably smart for the actor
not to try to do a direct impression, it still
might give some fans pause to see Han before
the weight of the galaxy got him down.
Production drama
Good press is key to a movie's success, and
Solo was plagued by negative rumors after
a rocky production, which included the firing
of directors Phil Lord and Christopher Miller.
Lord and Miller were said to have encouraged
more improvisation and a different tone than
the company wanted for the movie, so they
were replaced by Ron Howard.
Even though Howard is a talented replacement,
the behind-the-scenes turmoil associated with
the picture may have left a lot of fans skeptical
about the finished product.
And while reviews for the film were mostly
positive, they weren't as overwhelmingly favorable
as its predecessors.
Even some critics who said the film was entertaining
also said it covered old ground and didn't
bring anything new or different to the franchise.
Since word of mouth is essential for any movie
to succeed, Solo's ground campaign might've
been damaged by the initial bad buzz and ho-hum
critical reception.
Holiday haze
Memorial Day weekend used to be the reliable
start of the summer box office, but its grosses
have been in a downward spiral in recent years.
The last time the weekend offered up a $100
million-plus opener was in 2014, with X-Men:
Days of Future Past.
More recent offerings like Pirates of the
Caribbean: Dead Men Tell No Tales, Baywatch,
X-Men: Apocalypse, and Tomorrowland disappointed
in the same release time period.
While big movies like Jurassic World: Fallen
Kingdom and The Incredibles 2 are likely to
save this summer from being a complete disaster,
Solo was stuck in a period that's been growing
consistently worse in recent years, making
it the summer's first big flop.
Lingering competition
Most studios won't dare to challenge a Star
Wars movie, which is why it was the only major
release during its opening weekend.
However, the film still faced competition
from the second weekend of Deadpool 2 and
the fifth weekend of Marvel's Avengers: Infinity
War.
"He's trying to copy me."
Deadpool 2 was initially set to come out the
weekend after Solo, but Fox later moved the
release so that it hit theaters earlier.
And even though Infinity War has been out
for weeks, it's still a box office draw.
Solo might've managed to earn the top spot
at the box office on opening weekend, but
the ticket booth was still crowded with other
options that might've eaten away at its profits.
International struggles
While overseas markets have been known to
save some movies from obscurity, Solo doesn't
seem to be resonating with international audiences.
The film took in just $68 million in the international
markets after releasing in all major territories
except Japan.
With an already large budget pushed higher
by the movie's reshoots, international profits
were important for Solo, but it doesn't look
like the film will be able to turn there for
relief if it continues to flop domestically.
What does the movie's lackluster performance
mean for future Star Wars spinoffs?
"I've got a bad feeling about this."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!